so we're playing squish which is what
your whoa this looks pretty cool well
what's going on up there what am i don't
want i'm pice hi what what did i know
what I am what I'm sorry I'm sorry I
don't know what you guys think I did but
I done diddly diddly daesil didn't do
anything
the walls are closing my god
I have to get out of here I don't wanna
face quest please please I'm so added oh
uh but I said I'm gonna do anything I
didn't mean anything I do anything I do
anything I'll lick your ball no I won't
that's game
no there's anything wrong with that uh
okay okay
it's we can be friends how about that
I'll go on a date with your girlfriend
no no no no no no no no no it's not what
you think
she she hit on me I didn't know you know
is that it yeah I was brilliant
all right I hope you guys enjoyed sales
him man